Everything starts when my parents know in the Philippines
Mia, my lively, funny and charming mother
At that time, as a waiter
My father, Willie, is a Marine Corps officer.
And he has a sense of morality like Superman
He often describes himself as "boring but reliable"
My mom overslept when they first dated.
She also overslept on the second date.
So he bought her a gift, an alarm clock.
On the third date, success! :)
Except my mom is farting when she is about halfway through the date.
It’s in that moment, my mom knows that my dad is her true child.
Because he looked back at her and said:
"Are you stepping on the frog?"
They got married and gave birth to me, my brother Will and my sister Kristina.
As a military family, we move every two to three years.
To the new state, if not to the new country
When I was seventeen, Kristina killed herself.
My life is really a contrast before and after this critical moment.
This thing defines me, whether I want it or not.
It’s this thing that turned me into the present.
I started working on comedy when I was 19
Because that is the only thing that makes me laugh.
I was commuting to Los Angeles for two hours.
Do some live performances and shows
In the self-service laundry and coffee shop
I was finally able to move to Los Angeles when I was 21
I also started playing youtube.
I have several failed channels and broken friendships.
Until I found out that I was making progress on the recommendations and story-based videos, and I would play all the roles in the film.
I started taking a movie in a week.
Never stopped until now
If I really have to paint my life,
You will see the following things:
I am filming at home and using a computer.
At the filming scene, it may be the director or the actor.
Study
An impromptu performance or comedy on stage
I can’t be proud of the number of meals such as In N Out.
Drive to the conference and end the conference, drive, super conference, more to burst
Have dinner and watch movies with my boyfriend
Go to the gym three times a week
I am delaying my dentist clinic XD
I am going to audition
I will hold my cat whenever I get the chance.
I run a company
I am mixed with my friends.
I see all the shows are unrestrained.
Sometimes I feel depressed
You know, I will lie on the floor or in bed.
Or just look at the air in the dark, like a weirdo
Sometimes I will cry in the car without a reason.
I will read an article about the living conditions of livestock.
Or the proportion of teen suicide, then you will feel hopeless in life
Sometimes I drink too much and eat too little
Worried about what I know don't need to worry about
Until now, my life is trying to make myself famous.
I started my career and worked hard since I was 19 years old.
Doubt: "How do I become a better person?"
Or is there something I can bring to the world?
My life is hard work, fast pace of life
Still telling the truth, very confusing
Just realize that my parents are just people.
That is, everyone who has a sister
Is to define ourselves through loss, achievement and failure.
But I am still young
Life will continue to change, indicating the next stop, no matter what it is.
All I can say is that I am really lucky to be able to do what I am doing now.
Age is a privilege that some people can never have.
And I love my life.
Even when I am depressed and can't get up from the ground
Because there is always a cat?
Right, I mentioned that I have five cats?
I am Anna Akana. Continue to be a great person, Gotham.